außenreporterin Vanessa begrüßt euch
ganz herzlich zu vlogm Tag Nummer 8
heute haben wir uns was ganz
fantastisches überlegt denn Mailand
strotzt nur so und kotzt nur so vor
Sehenswürdigkeiten und die schauen wir
uns heute alle an ich habe eine Tour
rausgesucht dass wir eine Runde laufen
können und mal schauen wie lange wir
dafür brauchen aber jetzt fangen wir
erstmal an mit Sehenswürdigkeit Nummer 1
let's
go kommen wir zu unser ersten Station
die Kunstakademie Mailand die
Kunstakademie Mailand oder die Academia
di Belle Arti de Brera hat eine
faszinierende Geschichte die bis ins 18
Jahrhundert
zurückreicht gegründet im Jahr 1776 von
Maria Theresa von Österreich war sie
zunächst als private Institution
konzipiert im Laufe der Zeit entwickelte
sich die Akademie zu einem bedeutenden
Zentrum für die Ausbildung von Künstlern
und Kunstliebhabern berühmte Künstler
wiees und Boni waren absolventen dieser
ierten Einrichtung die Akademie
überstand politische Veränderungen und
Kriege und im beeindruckenden Innhof
steht die Statue von Napoleon Bonaparte
ein Symbol für die wechselvolle
Geschichte
[Musik]
Mailands also timus erste Reaktion auf
die Kunstakademie war hey ich dachte wir
gucken uns Sehenswürdigkeiten an doch
dann als wir um die Ecke gegangen sind
hat er gemerkt hier gibt's ganz schön
viel zu gucken und es ist einfach
beeindruckend oder diese Statuen das ist
man einfach nicht von zu Hause gewohnt
und das ist wirklich ein Grund hier mal
[Musik]
vorbeizuschauen hinter mir ist die
castelloco ich spreche hier nichts
richtig aus also spart euch die
Kommentare eine
die es schon sehr lange gibt aber lasst
uns erstmal
reingehen die Geschichte der Castello
sorzco ist so majestätisch wie die Burg
selbst errichtet im 14 Jahrhundert als
Festung wurde sie im Laufe der
Jahrhunderte Zeuge epischer
Veränderungen die Burg erlebte die
Herrschaft der Visconti und später der
mächtigen sworzer Dynastie die Sie zu
einem kulturellen Zentrum Mailands
machten im 15 Jahrhundert wurde die Burg
erweitert und erhielt eine prachtvolle
Fassade die bis heute beeindruckt in den
folgenden Jahrhunderten diente sie als
Residenz für Könige als Waffenarsenal
und als Museum für antike Kunst während
Napoleon die Burg in ein Symbol seiner
Macht verwandelte erlebte sie später
eine umfassende Restaurierung heute
beherbergt die Castellos forcesesco
Museen darunter die beeindruckende
Sammlung des Museo der Art Antika und
bleibt ein ikonisches Wahrzeichen dass
die kulturelle Reise Mailands durch die
Jahrhunderte
reflektiert das nenne ich mal ein
Schloss obwohl es für mich mehr aus wie
Burg aber auf google steht Schloss ist
das nicht beeindruckend also wenn man
sich vorstellt 1400 haben die angefangen
hier diese Anlage zu bauen das ist ein
langes Projekt jetzt gewesen es war of
zerstört aber jetzt für Touristen offen
schaut euch mal selbst an eure
Touristenführerin Vanessa geht jetzt zur
nächsten
[Musik]
Station wir stehen hier vor der Basil
Maria GRA die aktuell gerade geschlossen
ist also passt auf wenn ihr eure Besuche
plant die machen hier so Mittagspause
würde ich jetzt mal sagen und in diesem
Gebäude in dieser Basilika ist oder
hängt das letzte abendmah die Santa
Maria delle gratiie ist mehr als eine
Kirche sie ist ein heiliges Zeugnis der
Spiritualität und Kunst in Mailand
errichtet im 15 Jahrhundert beherbeckt
sie das berühmte Meisterwerk das
Abendmahl von Leonardo da Vinci diese
göttliche Allianz von Architektur und
Kunst macht die Kirche zu einem
spirituellen Juwel die gotische Struktur
und die erhabene freskenpracht schaffen
eine Atmosphäre der Ehrfurcht als UNESCO
Weltkulturerbe ist die Santa Maria delle
grazieie nicht nur ein Ort des Gebets
sondern auch ein heiliges Denkmal dass
die tiefen Verbindungen zwischen Glauben
und Kunst feiert leck mich am Arsch ein
geiler Text wier sehr beeindruckend das
einzige Problem ist nur das Abendmahl
können wir uns leider nicht anschauen
Timos Kamera ist viel zu groß als dass
sie uns damit durchlassen würden und
dann investieren wir doch lieber 30 €
die unsere zwei Tickets gekosten hätten
in unser
[Musik]
abendmah
was mir hier wirklich schnell
aufgefallen ist es gibt nicht so
wirklich Ketten also es gibt kein
Starbucks natürlich gibt's irgendwo in
Starbucks aber nicht so verbreitet jedes
Caffe und jedes Restaurant ist immer ein
Unikat ne
absolut wir stehen hier vor der
katholischen Kirche
hier gibt es viele bunte Bilder das
wollen wir mal sehen die San Maurizio
Kirche in Mailand hat eine spannende
Geschichte im 16 Jahrhundert als Kloster
gebaut wird sie oft als Sixtinische
Kapelle Mailands bezeichnet die Nonnen
auch bekannt als lmonarchi de San
Maurizio haben die Kirche mit
beeindruckenden Fresken und Kunstwerken
geschmückt das wurde alles handbemalt
timo ist kein Druck keine Tapete
rangeklebt es wurde handbemalt es ist
unfassbar obwohl kleiner als die
Sixtinische Kapelle ist sie genauso
prächtig die Kirche war nicht nur ein
Ort des Gebets sondern auch ein Zentrum
für Musik Künstler wie Bernardino Luini
haben hier ihre Spuren hinterlassen die
San Maurizio Kirche ist nicht nur ein
altes Gebäude sondern ein lebendiges
Erbe das die kulturelle Blütezeit von
Mailand zeigt ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass die Menschen schon
1550 Tiere malen konnten doch heute
wurden wir eines besseren belehrts
wirklich sehr sehr schön also ich
verstehe es warum man es die sextinische
Kapelle Mailands nennt ja sehr
beeindruckend und jetzt geht's weiter
diese Straßenbahn ist ebenfalls von 1500
schießmich tot wir wissen nicht ob die
Straßen immer so voll sind heute ist es
auf jeden Fall so denn es beginnt ein
Feiertag der sich vom 7 bis zum 10
Dezember zieht und deswegen ist heute
alles ganz besonders aber anders als in
Deutschland sind hier am Feiertag
natürlich die Geschäfte offen und da
wird ges geschopt geschopt das ist das
Wichtigste Wochenende vor Weihnachten
also das ist wirklich das Shopping
Weihnachtswochenende für die myänder
dieser Tannenbaum ist gesponser und
jetzt alle dieser Tannenbaum ist
gesponser von Boscolo mailand ist
einfach eine große Sehenswürdigkeit
schaut euch mal doch schon wieder dieses
Haus
an das steht hier einfach so keine
Ahnung
Police hinter uns laufen Polizisten die
Folgen uns wirklich Timo ja ja Film die
mal
für das ist aber auch krass wie die
trainiert sind dass sie sich nicht aus
der Ruhe bringen lassen ich möchte
lieber hinter den laufen oh haltet uns
den Weg frei aber macht keine Kacke sie
reiten den Sonnenuntergang ja ich kann
mit halten das ist voll praktisch weil
hinter denen ist alles frei man kann
jetzt richtig schön schnell laufen keine
Menschenmasse guck die gehen alle aus
dem Weg und wir
hinterher Hammer und wir näheren uns
jetzt auch schon unserer nächsten
Sehenswürdigkeit hier in Mailand ein
absolutes Goldstück von Sehenswürdigkeit
der maänder Dom auch unter dem Namen
dumo di Milano bekannt ragt majestätisch
empor und wirkt eine facettenreiche
Vergangenheit seine Ursprünge reichen
zurück ins 14 Jahrhundert und der Bau
erstreckt sich über mehrere Jahrhunderte
durch verschiedene architektonische
Epochen von gotisch bis zur Renaissance
unter dem Patronat unterschiedlicher
Herrscher darunter die Visconti Familie
und später die swarer Dynastie entstand
dieses architektonische Meisterwerk der
dumo war Zeuge bedeutender historischer
Ereignisse wie der Krönung Napoleons im
19 Jahrhundert die imposante Fassade
geschmückt mit Statuen und kunstvollen
Verzierungen erzählt eine Geschichte von
macht Kultur und dem Wandel der Zeit der
Mailänder Dom steht heute als
beeindruckendes Symbol dass die
Geschichte der Stadt auf eindrucksvolle
Weise wiederspiegelt ich glaube wir sind
uns alle einig da kann der Kölner Dom
einpacken und wir gehen jetzt zum Finale
und gleich um die Ecke vom myänder Dom
ist die Galeria Vittorio Emanuele der
zweite um es mit den Worten von Timo
braunsch zu sagen sie ist heute so krank
asozial voll wir wollten euch eigentlich
noch das Theatro al Scala zeigen das ist
ein sehr bekanntes opernhhaus hier was
wirklich weltbekannt ist doch das
schaffen wir einfach zeitlich nicht mehr
und es ist auch sehr schwer da
reinzukommen aber dafür gibt es hier
eine Live Übertragung nur heute aus dem
Theater
Scala ja bitte
schön passiert aber noch
[Musik]
nichts und das waren unsere Empfehlungen
für Mailand falls ihr noch einen
Geheimtipp habt schreibt den gerne in
die Kommentare rein ansonsten hoffen wir
das Video hat euch gefallen und kann
euch vielleicht für eure nächste
mailandreise weiterhelfen